fan you say you like to write about
themes of love
loss and lust once you know your themes
how do you develop them into a
screenplay
yeah um those are the things i'm really
drawn to and
what starts pretty much everything for
me once i have those themes
then i could build uh then i have the
characters
once i have those characters then i
could give them these goals you know
and then and then once they have goals
i'd like to
then create the world um that they're
they're in
but my worlds are really uh kind of
similar but i like worlds that are um
similar to how you know we're about to
fall asleep we hear someone
in the other room and it you can't tell
if it's
a dream but you know it's real it's that
stage and then your knee jerks
and you wake up and then so those are
the types of worlds i
i like to kind of create where it's like
grounded by
a gritty realism but it's you know
it has this kind of atmospheric haze to
it
that that but that borders on the edge
of
like a dream and a nightmare that kind
of feel to it so
so then have the characters and have the
theme
if i ever get lost with these characters
i i go find the theme
and now and then i'll have them swim
towards that
how did you create the tone and mood of
all roads to perrla similar i think i'm
drawn to
i'm drawn to shadows i'm drawn to to
those
the definition of love lust and loss and
how
a lot of times are those definitions
blend together your definition of love
might be my definition of lust your
definition of lust might be
my destiny definition of loss so it's
like
everyone has these things and and that
the tonality of it
actually was also kind of highly
inspired by um
john lennon's song mother have you heard
that song oh
it's like he wrote it he wrote it mother
yeah it's
it's he wrote it while he was going
through primeless scream therapy
and so it's like one of the first
recordings where you have like this uh
um singer really
screaming so so that was the
that was the um
uh kind of feeling i want the lyrics are
unbelievable it's like mother you had me
but i never had you
uh like father you left me but i never
left you so there's like this ache i was
like could i
i wish i could make something that that
felt so gritty and
and and powerful and painful and still
dealt with that
those definitions but also dealt with
family
a lot of things the a lot of um
another theme i like is family you know
family that ties in
of stuff so so um the tone of it
i wanted to have it like that had had
had it like a diane arby's photo where
it kind of
where you look at it a little bit too
long that gets even
a little bit scarier but it's real
that's real life you know it's
it's it's it's tied into that so yeah
that's that's how it sort of developed
the feel and tone of the the film what
is it about diane arbus's work that
you're so attracted to
i think you know
first it was the people her subjects
the people that she she wanted to
investigate and there were
people you termed on the fringes
or they called freaks or what have you
and i think that's all of us
you know and and it was really natural
really cool
to and that she explored a world that
that people maybe are scared to
um look at or overlook and i like i like
that i like those
little nuances and some of the things
that happen to us
sometimes we overlook some of the people
that you know
passes by they they have a life they
have
pain suffering hopes dreams and and
and i see that in her pictures and and
the art forms that i gravitate to
kind of elicit that for me like whether
it's music paintings
it makes me go go those places of wonder
new lands
new lands meaning like places where
uh it doesn't have to be grand it could
be down
the hallway the alley it's just new
wonderment you know
um and so uh i like
i like work that takes me there when did
john lennon write that song what year
was that
oh man in the 70s i would take it i'm
not too
i'm not exactly too sure but um
but yeah check out the check out the
youtube video of it
oh or the last part of it it's just like
because
prime screen therapy i if i correct is
you're supposed to let go of all your
traumas like how you're coming out of
the womb
and and you light it and scream scream
it through and
and um and have that aspect
yeah do you ever
watch old interviews with uh john lennon
like the dick cavett interview i think
he did a couple
i have not in recent times but i have
ears and
and and um but uh
that particular song just stuck more
more to me because i think it has
you know to do with with uh his mother
and things of that sort so yeah
and i also you know i had lost my mother
at the time so you know it was it was uh
kind of tied into that
you